[Applause]
here we go
all right
get my crap together happy wednesday
everyone oh yes you know it's always
good when dangerous products get
recalled
like say defective airbags
[Music]
or faulty gas pedals or flimsy
children's high chairs thank god they
recalled those i remember the nasty fall
i took at applebee's on my 40th
birthday but when something hurts
society you got to take it off the
market for some reason however the view
is the only exception
and who can forget my short-lived
company greg's fiery lawn darts
sounded like a good idea
our backyard toys making you yawn then
it's time to set fire to your
imagination and your lawn introducing
greg's fiery lawn darts it's all the
danger of 70s toys packed with modern
incendiary technology
wow
that's awesome
that's right kid and even if you miss
the target you can still set your tall
neighbor's yard ablaze it's fun for the
whole family plus we'll throw in this
summer's hottest new toy sandbox order
now
probably uh
probably shouldn't have sold those
during wildfire season
although the upside without all those
stupid trees i can see into my
neighbor's windows again
but worse than fiery lawn darts this
flaming a-hole chaser boudin
breaking news here at this hour the
associated press says that san francisco
has ousted that progressive district
attorney chester boudin
chesapude thank you evil shannon bream
chaser boude finally essa voters had
enough of the car break-ins the open-air
drug dealing the shoplifting and dispose
of their left ea like a used condom in
the tenderloin district
it was a long time come and his stance
on crime was softer than kevin spacey at
a girl scout jamboree
the message is clear if you're going to
have someone in charge of prosecuting
crimes maybe don't make it a progressive
former public defender who's also the
son of a terrorist
it's like putting one of bin laden's
kids in charge of the tsa
boudin or whatever his name is is the
son of kathy boudine and david gilbert
who were getaway drivers for the 1981
brinks armored car robbery in which two
cops edward o'grady and waverly chipper
brown and the brinks guard peter page
were murdered by their accomplices no
wonder boudin has a soft spot for
violent thugs perhaps they reminded him
of dear old mom
recently in sf a cab driver was beaten
to death by a psycho with a pipe and
boudin's office treated it as an
accidental death like the fiend was
swinging at mosquitoes and the cab
driver just wandered into his path the
whole thing was just a tragic accident
really i'm surprised boudin didn't sue
the pipemaker so no wonder the recall
was supported by 60 of the voters in
early returns even the crazy street
poopers said this guy's got to go
so do we
that's a clear majority something you
don't get unless you're voting on
something really obvious
like whether i'm better looking than guy
benson
now let's look at those numbers that are
still coming in
right see look at this right now
that's
89
believe i am more handsome than guy
benson
i mean who could be the 11 percent they
probably don't have hd tv
yeah i think we can call this one early
last guy to take a beating like that was
seen running out of amber hurd's
apartment
on fire tonight yeah so is the recall
election a good sign that voters are
finally done with these perverse
progressive experiments that turn the
criminal justice system into a catch and
release program for violent creeps i
mean this is sf where they call anyone
to the right of che guevara fascist
who's next george gascon we hope you
know the la that d.a whose killers are
getting tattoos of which i think is not
a good sign
perhaps new york's d.a alvin bragg who
makes d.a stand for dumbass
at least when it comes to fighting crime
remember he ordered prosecutors to stop
seeking prison sentences for many thugs
downgrading charges and cases including
armed robberies remember you could
brandish a gun and it wouldn't count as
long as you didn't use it
i wonder if they apply that logic to
flashers on the subway
asking for a friend
kill mead
the result an explosion in recidivism
criminals took advantage because unlike
politicians they may be lawless but
they're not stupid
now we know this rise in violent crime
coincides directly with the rise of
progressive das you want cause and
effect there it is but something's
happening now you look at this recall
following february's recalls of sf
school board members for spending all
their time renaming schools rather than
opening them during covid the only thing
worse than progressives not focusing on
kids is when they do
and boudin was one among a class of
progs who in a wave of victories in 2019
vowing to reform the criminal justice
system that they deemed racist and
unfair
and what happened after that well crimes
shot up like a times square junkie
boudin's reign was a bigger bomb than
the ones his mom whipped up in the
family kitchen
the radical change they pushed ending
cash bail no longer prosecuting crime
reducing census ended up creating more
crime and more misery for everyone else
especially minorities so whose system
ended up as more racist
it's the one who believed minorities
would have a higher tolerance for mayhem
so maybe the tide is turning and not
just in the city by the bay hopefully
now the streets might get safer not just
from dangerous criminals but also
dangerous da's
welcome
tonight's guest
he looks like he's one of the brooks
brothers host of the guy benson show guy
benson
she writes more than an octopus with
eight pens editor-in-chief of the
federalist molly hemingway
she's the contributor at fox whose arms
could pick locks
and
he uses the great barrier reef as a
loofah
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
guy good to be here not sure i approve
of the beard
can i comment on that actually because i
grew this specifically for you not just
because of our dms yes
but
because every time i'm on this show you
do the little intro yes you called me a
brooks brother and you're welcome and
thank you that's wonderful but you
always say i look 12. right you yes so i
grow a beard to rebut you yeah and then
you don't even make the joke halloween
costume
it's just painted on yeah this is real
it's like you're trying to sneak into an
r radiator and
i've done that
last weekend actually now the other
thing is your little fake pole uh-huh
that you just referenced in the
monologue i've never said this before
but stop the steal
this is outrageous yes it is you don't
know if that's uh fraudulent so you
can't say anything many people are
saying many people are saying
so were you surprised that uh boudin or
boudon or whatever his name is got
recalled no i think that he has been so
aggressively terrible that even the
people of san francisco have had enough
and that's an achievement yeah to be too
progressive for san francisco is amazing
so congrats to him at least on that
one detail of this that i found
interesting is if you look at the map of
the city and some of the local
journalists were pointing this out
the areas most likely to want to keep
him were white areas right white
progressives who think they know better
than people of color on their behalf who
overwhelmingly backed the recall of this
guy who was not just soft on crime i
think that's wrong i think he is almost
pro crime right pro-criminal certainly
in his policies and when you push people
hard enough whether it's those school
board members or this d.a even san
francisco can get something right and
here they have again so i guess
congratulations to them it's interesting
because you bring up those separate
neighborhoods it's the white leftist
loves to experiment on minorities with
their crazy ideas because it won't
affect them their their walgreens
doesn't close but in the minority
neighborhoods their walgreens will close
so they're on a they're un they're
unimpacted unaffected thank you
i prefer unimpacted
they are unimpacted
not impacted also or not impacted i'm
feeling not well molly welcome to the
show good to see you as always great to
be here enjoy your writing as always do
you think this is the beginning of
something it it has to be the beginning
of something because
just recalling this guy is nowhere near
sufficient to pull back on some of these
progressive policies and it is worth
remembering that he did what he promised
he was going to do when he campaigned
right he campaigned openly as a soft on
crime guy and it seems a little bit
unfair that he's punished for
accomplishing you know he kept his
campaign promises and now he's getting
punished that's a rarity right he
actually did because usually you come in
tough on crime and then it goes to hell
he goes i'm not going to do that you're
going to get mugged
you got mugged was his slogan in this
campaign promises made promises kept yes
exactly the logo is like feces
but clearly he stepped in it
oh well done see what i did there tyrus
uh
so it looks like the real victims won as
opposed to the like symbolic victims
that the left always chooses score one
for the affected yes i think we can say
that but
this is the problem with the woke and
the progressives there's never a
teachable moment with them
it's that's why it's insanity
if a landslide of people voted me out
my speech would have been very different
it would have started with something
like damn my bad i'm sorry yeah wow i
didn't i got the message i'll learn from
this no no he said we were out they they
spent more money than we did and they
outnumbered us and the evil republicans
tricked them right billionaires you know
how much money the gop spent on actors
to pretend to be thieves to rob
everybody and steal cars
i mean the budget is just like i mean we
all had the donations are like 500 bucks
a gop now it's the stuff they will make
up instead of just owning yeah they got
it wrong right and that's why
i disagree with
it's not going to change yeah because
they're not going to change they're just
going to regroup and continue with first
world problems and continue to attack
people on what they say on social media
opposed to what's actually going on in
the world today
excuse me
i had a little burp there
they don't grow up they don't go you
don't have to yeah they're the bulldozer
parents they're trying to push their
bulldozer agenda
on people in the real and who are
dealing with real stuff and real
problems and i'm glad they rejected it
yeah you know it's a small victory 60
cat that's six out of ten don't you
think that it would be great to have
autumn automated or automatic recall
votes just have them every six months or
a year why not because they don't that
they like to go on for three years right
yes actually i think that would be a
great idea
uh be and this is shouldn't be
surprising obviously i mean
it's like san francisco is also so it's
so liberal but it's also so expensive
like even when you don't have to you
know get your car windows replaced every
three days or whatever
people are busting into them and i hate
this idea that you know criminal justice
reform i thought was was you know a good
thing if it would have been done
correctly and focus on crimes that are
actually victimless because when
someone's like steals your stuff that's
not victimless like you buy the stuff
because you want it
yeah you don't want other people to just
take it but they've just completely
destroyed that with with all of this
stuff and violent crimes are up because
of it too so
not good it is why would you pay so much
to live somewhere that sucks so bad
because you were immune from it you can
live in new york city
and i i had a discussion with somebody
who lives in los angeles who's a
comedian he's like you know i don't know
what people are talking about it's
everything's great and then i ask him
where he lives and of course he lives in
a very nice area he's got a car service
as long as the city is great for rich
people it's great because you get you
get to eat all the good food you get to
go to all the concerts and all the plays
and you never get attacked because you
have you know you you never your feet
never touch the ground
that's the explanation yeah i've been
miserable everywhere i've lived that is
true and you find it away and you share
the misery it's really nice hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else